now we've got lots of fun questions for
you and fans like Colin Haynes dog asked
us to ask you what do you like most
about London and England they're so
they're so good to me the people to run
that site I I love the thing I love most
of items is the people the people are so
you know so cultured and so nice and
that's yeah yeah exactly and I sometimes
maybe I can try to talk like that but I
always I always go a little called me
and get my continent I try to talk like
that as a male person oh I'm American so
I just think that the people here are
just so nice and you know I think it's
because it's you guys are so happy that
if you want to get away from the
cloudiness you can take a $50 ryanair
flight or train to Paris or train
anywhere and you guys can be in paradise
so with us it's not quite the same but
you know I think we do think that London
is just there's there's like a little
electricity about the city and you know
that's this is the people and you've
been at Wimbledon as well we know why
you've been here and somebody wanted to
ask you you said on Twitter that you'd
met Downton Abbey's Michelle Dockery and
that she gave you all the secrets they
want to know what the secrets were so
still Colton sure I was so embarrassed
because I'm not the person to walk up to
someone and like tell them I just act
like I don't know they are Superman like
oh my gosh that's Lady Mary oh my gosh
this is Chris so I was like in the
corner and my I opened my mouth and said
that I was a big fan of the Downton and
they dragged me over to her and I looked
like I was a fan and it was even though
I am um anyway she was very nice though
she um she she gave me I don't know if
their secrets and if they are secrets I
have to keep them the secret she ruined
one of the things for me because I
didn't found finish the third season it
so she started off by doing that for me
and then saying something else and you
think British people are so nice
yeah she's in it my favorite shell for
me by the no gosh so another pen
question what do you order Starbucks or
whichever coffee Emporium is your one of
choice
I'm avid Starbucks and which everyone
makes fun of me for that because there's
probably a lot you know there's so many
amazing coffee places out there but I I
get it every single day I get a nice
round americano with half-and-half and
two splendas then sometimes I'm feeling
of interest I will get a venti and
sometimes I get the sausage and she's uh
something McMuffin that's McDonald's
well now they know I McDonald's a lot um
the sausage and cheese whatever muffin
tasty sausage danger yeah so yeah that's
good good to know yeah I'm having
Starbucks right now okay now Sony wants
to know what you like most about being
famous
I think with being on a TV show you have
ever to need to kind of talk to people
that you know and you wouldn't dive
opportunity to talk to him the people
that follow me on my social media which
is great and also you get to let people
know that the things you do on camera or
not you you know I mean I'm not I don't
know I'm kind of obviously like [ __ ]
and crazy and you know they always
talking and things event like the rules
I played the paths are just very proving
them I do a lot of eyebrow acting I kind
of always in kind of trying to be very
sexy which is not me in real life so
it's it's it's nice to with with you
know I don't know whether it be fame or
just having you know a following you get
to you get to I don't kind of your voice
for some people it's it's nice to kind
of
I hear from people from like the Midwest
cuz I'm from Kansas I heard from people
all the time saying that they have
dreams of doing what I do and you know
that if they whether they look up to me
for you know getting out of the Midwest
and pursuing a dream that I've had my
whole life that's nice to hear because
she's on you you can talk to them and
say you know this isn't this isn't you
know magic it's you just you if you want
something you go after it and you keep
trying until you get it and then you
know then least you have to try so that
sets that with that you can do that with
Fame you can do that so that's good
standard definitely and I live the i'ma
action Emma stay you happy and I just
it's just I don't know why that happens
but I don't know people always say that
they're having blood caterpillars and
they molt in fly away in the butterflies
somebody else wanted to know what movie
projects have you got any movie projects
coming up and if not what would you like
to do ideally they're you know they're I
don't have any right now coming up there
are a few there are definitely a few
possibilities for me right now they
would have to be they would have to work
into a schedule but with you know with
the success of the show I've had some
opportunities to really you know take
some of the great meetings and get
really close on a few projects obviously
the film it takes a lot of time and I've
been you know I've been really close in
a few projects to film before but
there's hasn't been the right time and
you know so I'm I hope that some of
these over are least one of these things
pan out and then it works out with the
schedule so it'd be nice to uh you know
it would be my first time doing movie
and I do know well I'll know very very
soon within the next few weeks if that's
gonna happen so what movies and TV shows
do you like to watch when you get a bit
down
you can't say Teen Wolf or arrow okay
there's something obviously Downton
Abbey but I'm done with that Michelle
dawn exactly so over it on my list and
she's on my actual list like an arrow
but uh um Kyle of shameless I actually
I've only caught a few of the of the
English version of the show but I I got
sucked into the American version which
is which is based off of the show here
and I think it's one of the most
underrated series on television the
ultimate sin really keV it's a great
kind of amazing show than that I've been
obsessed with right now and Breaking Bad
is also incredible I'm trying to get
through the first season right now but
it's making it makes me want to throw up
sometimes so I have to like walk away
but the acting is incredible and well so
I watch um hmm I always catch like if
I'm flipping through that she like TV
like the channels I always catch didn't
they call I don't have here but I love
HGTV which is like love it or listed or
like you know the property brothers it's
it's all these shows about town like
real estate than buying homes and you
know like things like that so I mean
pretty exciting stuff you thinking of
advice to find well - oh well I'm buying
a house for the first time at the
beginning of the year and obviously I
would like my homes to look like all of
these nice places but I am I wouldn't
say I'm cheap I mean that's a little -
going a little too far I would say is
frugal a better word advisable yeah I'm
cheap it's terrible but I would rather
you know I'd rather save them then on
some things I definitely splurge on some
things but yes fun a few fan questions
not a favorite city in the world
Banting and where would you like to go
oh that's a hard one favorite city in
the world I can do top three London
London Berlin Paris oh no I'm gonna have
to do I'll talk about tell Sydney
Australia courtesan oily as so many more
but I'm just gonna have to stop it there
and then yeah where else we'd like to
get even milk vignette I want to go to I
wanna go to Brazil I want to go to
Barcelona I want to go to China
um I wonder Japan I'm gonna go so many
places yet and I think I think I'm gonna
go to fuels voices fighting in a video
so Masada
you